All right, Charles welcome back, so let's let's see what you've come up with.
>> Okay, so I would choose for the second one support vector
machines, and the reason why is because there seems to be a single
line that seems to be in the middle between where the plus and
the minus are, so it looks like it's trying to maximize the margin.
>> Yeah, though, those aren't training points. I'm just labeling the regions.
>> Oh never mind. Well then I totally misunderstood. [LAUGH] to do.
I stand by it.
>> Yeah, I think it, I think that's a perfectly
fine answer because the sup, support basic vector machine is going
to find a linear separator. And so the output, the
classifier that comes out of it is going to separate any kind
of region into pluses and minuses, with some lines separating
them out. That's also true of perceptrons, it's also true of
certain kinds of you know, simple neural nets. So all those
seem like they would be reasonable answers for the middle one.
>> Oh okay well, then given
that, I'm going to say the third one is a nearest neighbors method.
>> good. And like what nearest neighbor do you think?
>> K nearest neighbor? [LAUGH]
>> Sure, I was thinking one nearest neighbor.
>> Yeah I was too actually, believe it or not.
>> One nearest neighbor. So we, I don't think we got a chance to draw
one of these diagrams when we were talking
about nearest neighbors. But this is called a,
>> Voronoi diagram?
>> Voronoi diagram! Right! Because what,
what's happening is, it's breaking up
the plane into the regions that are closest to some particular points.
>> Right.
>> So you give it a set of points,
it breaks up the plane into the things closest
to that. And in this particular case our We
had, we probably had three points. And one was labeled
plus, and another was labeled plus. One was labeled
minus, and so it break the space up into
these sections that way. So this, this should. Voronoi
diagrams can be very aesthetically pleasing I don't think I
drew this one particularly well.
>> I think it's perfect. My eyes are closed. I think it's
perfect. Given that, that I'm going to say the first one is decision trees.
>> Very good. Because decision trees split
things you know, if you're talking about
in, in a, in a two dimensional space it's going to split at the
top node in one dimension. And here it looks like that's this split. Then
maybe, looks like on the left side that's a minus. On the right side
there's another split. On the left side of that
it's a plus. On the right side there's another
split into pluses and minuses. You get these sort
of interesting nested rectangles. They also can be very pretty.
>> Right.
>> Very Mondrianish. Yeah, very good. So this
is not what we're going to talk about today.
>> Okay, good.